my buddies at the time had opened up uh  an after hours and it was in liberace's  old penthouse and it opened at 11 uh two  in the morning and he closed at like 11  in the next day and i was the only  bartender in there and uh i saw some  [ __ ] in that place wildest [ __ ] i've  ever [ __ ] like i would literally go  to my friends and go did you [ __ ] see  who's in that room you see what's going  on over there did you see this did you  see what's happening by the pool like it  was insane as a young kid who was so  enamored by hollywood it was like  someone brought you behind the wizard  curtain and i was like what the [ __ ] is  this big actors you're talking big  a-list actors i'm talking like oscar  winners i'm talking like i'm talking  like the biggest of the big from music  to acting to everything and i was like  holy [ __ ]